bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo episodio di alpinismo bale
vi ricordate com'era finito l'ultimo
episodio che io ho fatto questo c'è un
mare di acqua paura che vada tutto in
cortocircuito ecco bene nel pulire mi
sono visto che un gioco che ti porta a
morire dentro non sono messe d'accordo
io sì ma all inizio di episodio tutele
oggi sono infortunato ma nonostante
questo proviamo a fare livelli sulla
bici divieto di pesci mi sa che avevo
anche già provato a farlo questo non ero
riuscito ha ottenuto la tua band ad rana
ragazzi la partenza è buona speriamo
spaccar bottiglie anche stavolta
mannaggia il perfetto per bell a simili
conta da quel dì ciclo di morte che non
riuscivo a fare poi lasciato molto ha
detto vabbè lasciamo perdere
ok ok tutto bene ma poi era sempre
facile mi ricordo c'era un problema più
avanti un libro non mi ricordo dove
morivo le altre volte sincero però
vediamo se riesco ad arrivarci qua c'è
un ascensore
c'è un acquario vai bellissima e
bellissimo suo livello
[Musica]
va bene eccolo eccolo non sono morto
però attenzione posso ancora andare di
qua perfetto e infatti devo andare molto
più veloce prova bene dai che è in
questo è giusto
oddio
ho vinto gramma segno pensavo fosse
molto più lungo dio dio e che cos'è
questo c'è una palla gigante ma non è
servito a si ok questo anche me lo dico
sono difficilissimi
qua devo andare avanti devo fermarmi
proprio sotto lo scopo in modo tale che
la palla non mi prenda e poi andare
avanti dopo questo è un casino
questo è un casino ma di quelli veri
ragazzi questo è veramente difficile me
lo ricordo tribulato per due ore è addio
fuori come un puledro e non può essere
neanche tranquillo in un livello così
cioè sempre l'ansia addosso bombe via
perfetto non so dove sto andando ma fa
niente
va bene madonna come mi sono salvato
non so dove devo andare prendo la
rincorsa si ma non ho idea di dove tu
voglia mandarmi non ce l'ho ok ho fatto
giusto non sono anche come dove devo
andare di qua
tranquilli tutto a posto spero che tu mi
dia uno stop se mi devo fermare perché
non ho ben capito quest'anno c'è un
traguardo per caso mi farebbe molto
felice
visto e considerato che questi livelli
sono difficilissimi
io come potevo arrivare lì più veloce di
così lega da iezzi
oddio perfetto è tarato proprio dalla
precisione cioè ti passa al tar e
l'ansia in maniera incredibile perché
solo ansia salta perché non ne sono
sicuro vai vai vai vai tutto ok tutto ok
mega veloce e più veloce di così non
posso fare più veloce di così non si può
fare io stavo tutto pigiama ok non si
può fare non lo sa che lo potrebbe fare
perché non c'è il turbo io più di così
non potevo andare andavo al massimo
faccio un tasto quanto ho capito chi fa
saltare in alto
ok ok carino sono nello spazio ma
bellissimo 9 becks eliminare che mi
fermo qua effetto ora dovrei riuscire ad
andarci borsa eccolo qua e non lo stop
che devo schiacciare chiaro molto
difficile ma capito ma perché la verità
ma perché è un salto normale
me lo ha fatto lui l'ha notato la nota
lato malissimo sto livello perché mali
testano i livelli prima di farli non ho
fatto niente ha fatto lui mi va storto
non è colpa mia
mannaggia il cacchio e laici prova
l'ultima volta mannaggia a voi con i
piedi almeno sono tarati quelli col
padre di più che li hanno fatti per caso
già praticamente non ne hanno poi
neanche testati mannaggia al di volo
riproviamoci alla mi fermo con lo stop e
finco l'abbiamo fatto di sopra ci provai
per farmi andare molto più veloce
perfetto perfetto perfetto slow un
cacchio mamma mia
c'è praticamente il traguardo me lo
mettono all'inizio da dove sono partito
perché fa arrivando lì qual è il
problema
ok ok ok
peccato cacchio questa roba fa ragazzi
manca pochissimo poi ho fatto più
tentativi in questo che è bisogno di è
prevista la mia vita ed è tutto dire
tutto a posto
nel momento di provarci ragazzo perfetto
all'indietro
[Musica]
riproviamoci la gara è stavolta ci metto
ancora più di impegno come ha fatto
scassarci fa niente ma niente
comunque questi livelli di happy sono
molto interessanti però fare il sesto di
giorno sacro non ho già che lo adoro
raga non lo sa che basta andare con
razzo ed è tutto a posto però perché il
razzo è fortissimo ci vogliono già anche
nei livelli normali e personale non a
ciò che è over power c'è il razzo era
veramente la feature migliore dove
dobbiamo andare se non dovevo andar
latex e non ho capito dove devo andare
meglio proprio dentro la bocca del t rex
giusto era la mia seconda opzione è che
per chi non vorrebbe entrare dentro la
bocca di un tirannosauro chi non
vorrebbe mi sembra giusto mi date un
traguardo vi prego che ciò l'ansia solo
a giocare a questo gioco
nice no
a macao dove sto andando
beh va beh va beh ragazzi allora ultimi
due tentativi mi vedo ancora due le
possibilità e che ci sto provando
veramente impegnandomi fermati fermati
almeno due vittorie oggi ci sono
questo pero di aprire sale volte faccio
20 vittorie in un episodio sole volte ne
faccio una ma com'è possibile fin qua ci
siamo tutto a posto o che dentro la
bocca del tirannosauro manca un
tentativo comunque parole questo video
sia stato di vostro gradimento ragazzi è
stato molto difficile
sai qual è il problema è che the uk sono
fatti con quelli non sa che ancora
ancora quegli anni erano fatti bene sono
sono difficili il problema è che giocare
con questo mi penalizza parecchio però
non fa niente io li avevo forse fino ai
ragazzi siete dal canale ciò che mi
piace e mattino
[Musica]